[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne
gellineck guten Abend es kommen zu viele
wir müssen mehr und schneller abschieben
hatte Bundeskanzler Scholz am Wochenende
dem Spiegel gesagt mit Blick auf die
steigenden
Asylbewerberzahlen heute ließ seine
Innenministerin Taten folgen nenn sie
fäer präsentierte im Kabinett einen
Gesetzesvorschlag nachdem falls das Wort
passt besser und effizienter abgeschoben
werden soll die Zahlen der ankommenden
wird das nicht senken und das mit dem
abschieben bleibt schwierig denn der
größte Teil abgelehnte Asylbewerber wird
geduldet in Deutschland weil sie aus
Kriegsgebieten kommen oder Ihr Heim Land
sie nicht zurücknimmt und Kritik am
Entwurf kommt auch aus der Ampel selbst
Klaus brotbeck berichtet aus
Berlin beinahe wirkt es als gäbe es
heute etwas zu feiern die
Innenministerin am Morgen im Kabinett
seit Monaten steht die Ampel in der
Migrationsfrage in der Kritik das soll
sich nach des Kanzlers Ansage vom
Wochenende ab heute
ändern wir sehen ein Bündel restriktiver
Maßnahmen für mehr und schnellere
Rückführungen vor das ist notwendig
damit wir weiterhin unserer humanitären
Verantwortung für die Menschen gerecht
werden können die wir vor Krieg und
Terror schützen müssen wer kein
Bleiberecht hat muss unser Land wieder
verlassen das z.B soll sich ändern die
Polizei soll künftig in
Sammelunterkünften mehr Räume als nur
die Zimmer der Abzuschiebenden
durchsuchen dürfen Abholungen auch
nachts vornehmen können und der
ausreisegewahrsam sollon von 10 auf 28
Tage verlängert werden außerdem sollen
Schlepper und organisierte Kriminelle
leichter und schneller abgeschoben
werden können die Grünen in der
Regierung stimmten dem Gesetzentwurf in
der sogenannten resortabstimmung zu doch
zumindest in Teilen tut sich die Partei
schwer damit Grüne im Bundestag
jedenfalls kündigen schon mal
Änderungsbedarf an na der Gesetzentwurf
bedeutet in erster Linie schwere
Eingriffe in die Grundrechte auf und
auch Unverletzlichkeit der Wohnung und
deswegen heißt es nachbessern im
parlamentarischen Verfahren das was real
und am meisten hilft sind auf der einen
Seite die Bekämpfung von Fluchtursachen
in den Herkunftsländern also dort ganz
konkret die Situation vor Ort zu
verbessern denn niemand sollte auf den
lebensgefährlichen Weg über das
Mittelmeer müssen und eine Maßnahme die
wir hier in Deutschland voranbringen
wollen sind sogenannte
migrationsabkommen in Ministerium
angesiedelt verhandelt darüber intensiv
der migrationsbeauftrag sorgte der
Bundesregierung Joachim Stam FDP mit
Mitteilungen zu bevorstehenden Abkommen
ist er sparsam stammspartei lobt den
Gesetzentwurf von heute setzt aber
weitere Forderungen
drauf darf weniger attraktiv sein nach
Deutschland in die sozialen
Sicherungssysteme zu migrieren und ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt ist das Bargeld
Auszahlung an irreguläre Migranten
eingestellt werden auch Polizeivertreter
begrüßen die erweiterten Möglichkeiten
durch den Gesetzentwurf verlang eine
Zeitenwende auch hier wir fordern im
Kontext der aktuellen bedrohungs und
Sicherheitslage in der Bundesrepublik
ein Sondervermögen innere Sicherheit die
Bundeswehr hat ein solches
Sondervermögen bekommen für die innere
Sicherheit in Deutschland ist
mittlerweile sehr dringend notwendig
mehr Ressourcen mehr Geld und Personal
zur Verfügung stellen weiter also geht
es um Prinzipien dringend nötige Erfolge
und um Geld wenig Grund zu
feiern bedingungslos ist die
Unterstützung des Westens für Israel und
wie viel Empathie für das Schicksal der
Palästinenser ist verhältnismäßig dieser
Streit ist gestern auf der Bühne des
unwtsicherheitsrats offen ausgebrochen
un- Generalsekretär guteresch hatte in
seiner Rede gesagt dass die Angriffe der
Hamas auf Israel nicht im Zitat
luftleeren Raum entstanden sein und
sprach von der erdrückenden Besatzung
der Palästinenser durch Israel
die Empörung in Israel ist riesig und
mit ihr die Sorge dass die
Weltöffentlichkeit angesichts der Bilder
aus Gasa aus Opfern Täter macht Tim
Kröger berichtet aus Tel
Aviv Tel Aviv heute Nachmittag nur
langsam kommt das Leben zurück nach dem
hamasmassaker am 7 oktober von
Normalität kann keine Rede sein der
eklar von gestern im UN Sicherheitsrat
und die Worte von Generalsekretär gteris
stoßen auf
Verständnis ich kann nicht begreifen wie
ein Mensch sehen konnte was am 7 Oktober
passiert ist und wie man so etwas sagen
kann ich glaube die Vereinten Nationen
machen weiter wie seit
Jahrzehnten sie wählen eine Seite und
haben kein Verständnis für unsere
Lage un Generalsekretär g hatte die
Terrorangriffe der urteilt sie aber auch
mit Israels Besatzungspolitik in
Verbindung gebracht heute in New York
der Versuch einer Klarstellung er fühlt
sich
missverstanden ich bin schockiert wegen
der missinterpretation meiner Worte
gestern im Sicherheitsrat von
einigen so als hätte ich die Terrorakte
der Hamas
gerechtfertigt das ist falsch das
Gegenteil ist der
Fall
der eklar spiegelt einmal mehr wieder
wie sehr die Nerven blank liegen im
Nahen Osten noch immer ist unklar ob und
wann Israel Bodentruppen in den
Gazastreifen schickt und sich der
Konflikt zu einem Flächenbrand ausweiten
könnte israelische Regierungschef hält
offenbar weiter daran
fest wir bereiten uns auf eine
Bodenoffensive vor ich werde nicht sagen
wann und wie sie stattfindet und wie
umfangreich
diese Überlegungen sind nicht für die
Öffentlichkeit bestimmt nur so können
wir die Sicherheit unserer Soldaten
gewährleisten die massiven israelischen
Luftangriffe auf den Gazastreifen gehen
der Wall weiter auch im Süden wohin sich
viele geflüchtet haben die Lage der
Zivilbevölkerung wird laut
Hilfsorganisationen immer
schwieriger Angriffe zum Glück beschützt
uns Gott ich habe zur Miete gewohnt wo
soll ich jetzt hingehen es gibt keine
Unterkünfte nur die Straße in Israel
schlugen am Abend Raketen aus Gase ein
und die Streitkräfte veröffentlichten zu
dem Bilder die zeigen sollen wie sie auf
See hamasterroristen daran hindern
erneut nach Israel einzudringen ein Ende
des Krieges ist nicht
absehbar und darüber wollen wir reden
mit unseren Korrespondenten in Brüssel
und in Tel Aviv zuerst zu Michael
bwerunge in telaviv in Israel Michael
US-Präsident Biden hat heute abend
israelische Siedler kritisiert wegen
ihrer Angriffe auf Palästinenser im
Westjordanland wie groß ist die Sorge in
Israel dass das Land den Kampf der
Bilder und die Unterstützung des Westens
in diesem Krieg
verliert also ich glaube den politischen
Akteuren in Israel ist klar dass sie den
Kampf um die Bilder längst verloren
haben so wie sie sie ih auch in der
Vergangenheit eigentlich stets verloren
haben und
der die Kampf geht um die Unterstützung
und die
Bilder die den 7 Oktober geprägt haben
wie man an der Äußerung von guterresch
gesehen hat die verblast angesichts der
täglichen Bombenangriffe in Gaza die
Frage ist also was zählt wer unterstützt
wirklich in der arabischen Welt scheinen
die Fakten nicht so zu interessieren die
westlichen Europäer werden auch
wahrgenommen es bleibt eigentlich nur
die USA die sind der einzige wichtige
Partner und da wird dann auch umgekehrt
ein Schuh draus wenn man die Mahnung von
Joe Biden sieht doch bitte mit der
Gewalt der Siedler anders umzugehen die
Israelis werden darauf erst wirklich
reagieren wenn die USA wirklich Druck
machen also vielleicht den ersten Cent
für Waffenlieferungen einsparen vorher
sind das Lippenbekenntnisse die es auch
in der Vergangenheit gegeben hat und
Israel wird darauf keine große Rücksicht
nehmen danke Michael und gehen wir
weiter zu Florian neuhn in Brüssel und
zu den europä äischen Partnern Florian
die EU trifft sich morgen zu ihrem
herbstgipfel Unterstützung für Israel ja
aber sind daran Bedingungen geknüpft und
wenn ja welche na genau darüber wird
jetzt in den letzten Stunden vor diesem
Gipfel noch intensiv hinter den Kulissen
verhandelt und da geht es wirklich um
jeden einzelnen Buchstaben das ist
ehrlicherweise nicht übertrieben um mal
ein Beispiel zu nennen in der ersten
vorläufigen Version der
Abschlusserklärung von Montag die mir
vorliegt da hier hat es noch geheißen
dass die EU sich der Forderung des un
Generalsekretärs guteres nach einer
humanitären Feuerpause
anschließe das aber hieße ein quasi ein
längerer Waffenstillstand in dem Israel
nicht angreifen dürfe und das ging
einigen Vertretern die Israels Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung schützen und stärken
wollen wie Deutschland deutlich zu weit
jetzt gibt es eine neue Variante dieser
Erklärung von heute Nachmittag und da
hat man dieser erstens den Namen
guterrisch daraus gestrichen und
zweitens noch vielleicht wichtiger dem
Wort Feuerpause einen Buchstaben
angefügt ein N nämlich und fordert nun
humanitäre Feuerpausen das wäre etwas
völlig anderes das wähend kurze Pausen
vielleicht eine oder zwei Stunden am Tag
in den in Israel nicht angreifen dürfte
um man eben humanitäre Hilfen zu
ermöglichen es kann also sein dass sich
Europa nach einem Kraftakt auf eine
solche Forderung verständigt die große
Frage ist dann nur hat es auch die Kraft
diese Forderung durchzusetzen ja und da
haben auch viele Diplomaten mit denen
ich heute sprechen konnte doch ihre ich
würde sagen berechtigten Zweifel danke
Florian über nächtliche Textarbeit in
Brüssel und an Michael nach
telaviv für Wladimir Putin könnte es im
Moment nicht besser laufen der Überfall
der Hamas Terroristen auf Israel hat die
Aufmerksamkeit des Westens in den Nahen
Osten gelenkt und sicher spekuliert
Putin auch darauf dass als Folge weniger
Militär Hilfe in die Ukraine fließt der
russische Präsident hat ein schwieriges
Verhältnis zum Nahen Osten zunächst
baute er freundschaftliche Beziehungen
zu Israels Premierminister Netanyahu auf
doch seit der annextion der Krim kühlt
das Verhältnis zu Israel ab Putin
kümmerte sich lieber darum seine
Position als Führer der
antiamerikanischen Welt zu festigen und
dazu gehört auch der Kontakt zur
Terrortruppe der Hamas Armin Körper
berichtet aus
Moskau ob Moskauer Bürger hier Blumen
und Kuscheltiere für die Opfer von Gaza
hingebracht haben man weiß es nicht so
genau auf jeden Fall sind sie da wie
gerufen genauso wie die arabischen
Botschafter die heute morgen Solidarität
mit ihrem palästinensischen Kollegen zur
Schau tragen und der seine mit Präsident
Putin wir schätzen die russische
Position denn russland ist der festen
Überzeugung dass wir das Recht auf einen
een Staat
haben dabei waren eigentlich sie
ziemlich beste Freunde 22 Mal haben sich
Putin und der Israeli Netanyahu
insgesamt getroffen doch auf einmal hat
russlands Präsident größtmögliches
Mitleid mit den Palästinensern und wenig
mit dem Freund von
einst wir sollten die Dinge beim Namen
nennen israel reagiert auf einen Angriff
aber mit brutalen
Methoden und dann Gre der die gchichte
zu deutschen Nazis und dem Großen
Vaterländischen
Krieg gegen den Gazastreifen werden
sowohl militärisch als auch nicht
militärisch die gleichen Maßnahmen
ergriffen wie bei der Belagerung von
Leningrad im Zweiten
Weltkrieg wir alle wissen was das
heißt dieser Vergleich zwischen Gaza und
Leningrad ist natürlich also ist
natürlich absolut nicht richtigil im
Grunde genommen Israel mit dem Deutschen
Reich deinsetzen und das andere ist
natürlich dass man auch versucht die
eigene Kriegsführung in der Ukraine vor
dem eigenen russischen Volk zu
rechtfertigen ganz nach dem Motto se her
wir sind nicht so schlimm wie Israel der
Krieg in narost hat erschütterungswellen
bis nach Moskau ausgelöst oder war es
umgekehrt es war jedenfalls Putins
Geburtstag als die Hamas Israel
überfiel gut zwei Wochen zuvor Russlands
Verteidigungsminister in teiran es mag
Zufall
sein mindestens zweimal sind hamasführer
im vergangenen Jahr auf Besuch in Moskau
aufgetaucht und Präsident Putin kaum hat
das Morden begonnen sucht er auch schon
den Schulterschluss in Peking per Video
call fragen wir Michael peliwert der in
Israel forscht ob das alles Zufall ist
ich habe keine Beweise dafür dass
Russland hinter der militärischen
Eskalation im Nahen Osten steckt aber
ich bin mit den Handlungsmethoden der
russischen Geheimdienste einigermaßen
vertraut und daher kann ich es leider
nicht
ausschließen offensichtlich ist dass der
Krieg in narostrussland wie gerufen
kommt weil er die Aufmerksamkeit der
Welt von der Ukraine ablenkt und den
Westen verunsichert und beim Blick auf
Blumen und Kuscheltiere für Gaza mag man
sich fragen ob alles in Moskau wirklich
so ist wie es auf den ersten Blick
aussehen
soll
beim vierten Anlauf hat es endlich
geklappt in den USA haben die
Republikaner es geschafft einen neuen
Vorsitzenden des Repräsentantenhauses zu
wählen und damit beginnen die
Nachrichten von gundo lag Gause nach
wochenlangem parteiinternen Machtkampf
ist der Republikaner Mike Johnson neuer
Vorsitzender des
usreäsentantenhauses seit der
beispiellosen Abwahl von Kevin McCarthy
Anfang Oktober war die Kongresskammer
ohne Führung und damit nicht
handlungsfähig wegen der Partei internen
Querelen der Republikaner waren zuvor
drei Kandidaten gescheitert Johnson ist
Unterstützer von Ex-Präsident
Trump Deutschland hat der Ukraine
weitere 195 Millionen Euro Unterstützung
zugesagt für die Energieversorgung und
den Erhalt von Unternehmen in dem von
Russland angegriffenen Land die
russischen Drohnen und Raketenangriffe
DAU an erneut betroffen die Region
herson im Süden der Ukraine offenbar
konnte die ukrainische Luftwaffe viele
Drohnen abfangen und zerstören beim
Einschlag einer russischen flugbombe in
ein Wohnhaus kam ein Mensch ums
Leben gegen den in Duisburg
Festgenommenen islamistischen Gefährder
ist Haftbefehl erlassen worden laut
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Düsseldorf
soll sich der 29-Jährige gebürtige
Deutsche gegenüber einem chatpar Partner
in Syrien bereit erklärt haben einen
islamistisch motivierten Anschlag auf
eine proisrael Demonstration zu verüben
wegen Mitgliedschaft im is saß er
bereits 5 Jahre in
Haft erneut haben bombendendrohungen
gegen Schulen und verschiedene
Medienhäuser in mehreren Bundesländern
Polizeieinsätze ausgelöst alle Fälle
wurden geprüft die Sicherheitsbehörden
gaben schnell Entwarnung Absender und
Hintergründe sind bekannt der
Staatsschutz ermittelt den Tätern drohen
hohe Geldbußen und
Haftstrafen nach demem Zusammenstoß
zweier Frachter auf der Nordsee zwischen
Helgoland und langeog geht das
Havariekommando davon aus dass die vier
noch vermissten Seeleute ums Leben
gekommen sind die Suche wurde
eingestellt auch ferngesteuerte
Tauchroboter fanden keine Lebenszeichen
in dem gesunkenen Wrack die Zahl der
Todesopfer liegt damit bei F unklar ist
weiterhin die Unglücksursache die
Staatsanwaltschaft Hamburg hat
Ermittlungen
aufgenommen Globalisierung also
wirtschaftliche Verflechtung ist eine
gute Sache eine die Sicherheit und
Wohlstand fördert darin waren wir bis
vor kurzem alle einig und Deutschland
als Exportweltmeister fand das sowieso
dann aber kam die Rivalität zwischen den
USA und China die Pandemie und der
ukrainekrieg und plötzlich merkten wir
dass Deutschland abhängig ist vom
russischen Gas und noch mehr von China
keine Medikamente ohne chinesische
Vorprodukte
Huawei Komponenten sind wichtiger
Bestandteil deutscher
Mobilfunknetze und China lässt die
Europäer seine Macht spüren Elisabeth
Schmidt berichtet von einem Tripp zur
Konzernzentrale von
Huawei die Skyline der Hightech
Metropole schönjön ist in Sichtweite
wenn man in der Huawei Linie 1 durch das
Retorten Europa fährt das der
konzerngründer als firmenkampus bauen
ließ von einer Haltestelle zur nächsten
bummelt man von Paris über Bologna und
oxfd nach Rom oder
Heidelberg selten bekommen westliche
Medien hier Einblicke wir wurden
eingeladen zu einer exklusiven
Tour sind wir und das ist ein
fahrerloses
Auto autonom und futuristisch geht es
durch die Kopie von Heidelbergs
romantischen Gassen die scharmoffensive
von Chinas technologieriesen zielt auf
die Bundesregierung ab gut die Hälfte
der Komponenten und Antennen im
deutschen Mobilfunknetz stammt von
Huawei Berlin sieht in der chinesischen
5g Technik ein Sicherheitsrisiko China
so die Befürchtung könnte Deutschland
ausspionieren lassen Huawei bestreitet
das wir als Ausrüster haben keinen
Zugriff keinen Fernzugriff auf Daten in
Mobilfunknetzen noch auf die Steuerung
diese Szenarien von Spionage und auch
Sabotage gehören eher ins Reich von
Science Fiction doch Chinas nationales
Sicherheitsgesetz verpflichtet
Unternehmen zur Transparenz gegenüber
Partei und Staat in den USA sind huawe
Komponenten deshalb längst verboten
Huawei zu verbieten sei ein großer
Fehler sagt victtor gaau der die Meinung
der Kommunistischen Partei
wiedergibt wenn sich die deutsche
Regierung selbst ins Knie schießen will
bitte wir können euch nicht stoppen
wissen Sie wir können die Leute nicht
davon abhalten all die dummen Dinge zu
tun die dem deutschen Volk all die
Schäden Verletzungen und Verluste
zufügen
würden es ist ein aggressiveres China
mit dem Deutschland heute zu tun hat
ziel ist eine neue von Peking angeführte
Weltordnung mit einem Mann der als
Kriegs cher gesucht wird teilting eine
großmachtfantasie was für Vladimir Putin
die Ukraine ist füri Taiwan er will die
demokratisch regierte Insel ins
Mutterland zurückholen wie es offiziell
heißt notfalls auch mit Gewalt auch für
Deutschland hätte das fatale Folgen ein
Wegfallen der Märkte würde beiden
Volkswirtschaften schwer schwer Schaden
wir hätten Versorgungsengpässe und wir
hätten
Massenarbeitslosigkeit wie also
unabhängiger werden von China bei einem
drohen die deutschen Netzbetreiber
bereits mit Schadenersatz klagen die
Bundesregierung probiert es mit einem
vorsichtigen Kompromiss es wird erstmal
nur ein kleiner aber wesentlicher Teil
der Huawei Technik verboten und von
China mehr Transparenz
gefordert aber auch bei unserem
stundenlangen Besuch im kulisseneuropa
von Huawei haben wir von Chinas megatech
Konzern nur die Fassaden
gesehen über die gefährliche
Abhängigkeit Deutschlands von China und
die Frage wie es dazu kommen konnte
sehen sie gleich mehr in unserer
auslandsjournal Doku im Rachen des
Drachen gleich nach dem heutejournal um
22:15 Uhr und wir machen hier weiter mit
Nachrichten und gundola Gause und
bleiben beim Thema Wirtschaft erstmals
seit 6 Monaten hat sich die Stimmung in
der deutschen Wirtschaft wieder
verbessert dem aktuellen
Geschäftsklimaindex des ifo Instituts
zufolge sind die Unternehmen etwas
zufriedener mit den Lauf Geschäften
franketmann an der Börse könnte das eine
Trendwende sein die mutigen sagen ja die
etwas vorsichtigeren sind trotz der
Aufhellung keinen Grund für eine
konjunkturuphorie zu unterschiedlich die
Stimmungen in den einzelnen Branchen im
Tourismus und bei vielen Dienstleistern
sieht es durchaus gut aus am Bau und im
Handel ist die Stimmung aber nach wie
vor eh schlecht also weder Fisch noch
Fleisch das ganze gerade was der
Wirtschaft helfen würde wäre ein
tatsächlich Abbau der Bürokratie das
Bundeskabinett hat heute Eckpunkte auf
den Weg gebracht richtige Richtung in
Teilen beispielsweise sind die
verkürzten Aufbewahrungsfristen für
Belege sehr gelobt worden was
Steuererklärungen für die Betriebe
vereinfacht der große Wurf ist es aus
Sicht der Wirtschaft aber nicht
Stichwort schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren die sollen im
wesent Wesentlichen für erneuerbare
Energien kommen nicht aber für
zahlreiche andere industrielle Vorhaben
insgesamt so eine Umfrage des di HK
bleibt die überbordende Bürokratie ein
großes Problem für 72% der Befragten ist
die öffentliche Verwaltung zu langsam
und zu unflexibel die Wirtschaft mahnt
vor allem also Tempo an die Regierung
müsse nun auch liefern sonst sei der
Wirtschaftsstandort ernsthaft in Gefahr
heißt es Frank betmann vielen Dank
gerne fast die Hälfte aller Menschen
afrikanischer Herkunft in der EU erlebt
im Alltag Diskriminierungen einer
Umfrage der EU-Agentur für Grundrechte
in 13 EU-Ländern zufolge gibt es in
Deutschland die meisten klagen über
Rassismus hierzulande gaben 76% der
Befragten an aufgrund ihrer Hautfarbe
ihres
Migrationshintergrundes oder ihrer
Religion diskriminiert worden zu sein
insgesamt wurden EU-weit rund
6700 Menschen
befragt die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch lauten ohne Gewehr
25 31 49 Superzahl 7 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf lottozf.de und im ZF
Text auf Seite
557 in München sind am Abend die
bayerischen Fernsehpreise verliehen
worden blaue Panther TV und Streaming
Awards heißen sie heute und ehren
Medienschaffende den Ehrenpreis für
prägende Leistungen im deutschen
Fernsehen erhielt unsere Kollegin
yahayali Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder
würdigte sie für ihren klaren Kompass
gegen Rassismus Frauenhass und
Diskriminierung von Minderheiten sowie
für ihr Wirken weit über die Grenzen des
Fernsehens in unsere Gesellschaft
hinaus Glückwunsch von uns allen
Dunja deutsche Behörden sind so ziemlich
das uncoolste was man sich vorstellen
kann Bürokratie Faxe pedantische Beamte
enreiter dazu notorisch ineffizient
Quatsch sagt eine die es wissen muss
weil sie nämlich selbst als Beamtin in
der Berliner Verwaltung gearbeitet hat
jetzt macht sie sich hauptberuflich über
deutsche Beamte lustig allerdings mit
einer gewissen Sympathie als
amtsfluenzerin und hat den Beamtenjob
gekündigt Sebastian Gorski hat sie
getroffen manchmal braucht es
tatsächlich nicht mehr als ein bisschen
Langeweile während Corona eine gute Idee
und lustige Instagram Filter fertig ist
die Kunstfigur Conny from the
block hallo Malzeit ihr Lieben ich grüße
Euch eine ehemalige Berliner Beamtin die
mit ihren Social Media Videos das
behördenimage aufbessern will und dabei
liebevoll mit amtsklischees spielt so
ihr liben seid ihr bereit für unsere
Englischstunde was meint ihr denn was
heißt gerneschehen B
jetzt nicht hin und her schwafel bitte
das kennen wir alle was heißt ich bin
nicht zuständig das breite in der
Behörde alles aufeinander also man
arbeitet da in Teams da sitzt dann der
Ossi neben dem Wessi neben der buomerin
neben der 23jährigen Türkin und dann
kommt da noch der Araber der 35 ist
frisch vom vom Studium und der Z
Führungskraft ist und du denkst was ist
das für eine Konstellation hier ne und
das muss irgendwie funktionieren
deswegen muss man hinter die Fassade
gucken der Menschen
die reale Person hinter Conny will
anonym bleiben nur so viel sie ist in
Neuköln geboren und aufgewachsen ihre
Eltern aus der Türkei als Beamtin hat
sie selbstbehördenversagen die mangelnde
Digitalisierung und fehlenden Nachwuchs
erlebt genug Material für ein Buch mit
dem passenden Titel da bin ich nicht
zuständig Mausi und ihre online
Satire habt ihr auch ein
Systemupdate gibt nicht besseres als ein
Systemupdate ich les Zeitung hab da
davon von E Digitalisierung nicht böse
ihr meint also ich kenne kaum jemanden
der von der Behörde hört oder von dem
Amt hört und denkt oh toll das wollte
ich schon immer tun wow erstmal ist es
ein Image was was da ist oder schon
immer da war dann bestätigt sich das
hier und da auch tatsächlich
mal und die Sache ist was noch wirklich
ein Problem ist ist es fehlt ganz viel
Infos also was macht man in der Behörde
überhaupt deswegen ist die Mission der
selbsternannten amtsfluenzerin aufklären
niedrig schwellig mit einem zwinkernden
Auge und für mehr Vielfalt auf dem Amt
zu werben ob es jetzt die
Ausländerbehörde ist ob es
geflüchtete sind
ob es Menschen mit Behinderung sind
queer Trans das alles versuche ich so
ein bisschen zu verpacken weil Behörden
auch für die da sind und meiner Meinung
nach Behörden das aber noch viel zu
wenig spiegeln wir sagen wir sind bunt
sind wir aber nicht so bin ich
sorry Amt aber glücklich ein
aussichtsloses Unterfangen für die Conny
mit den lustigen Gesichtern zumindest
einen unterhaltsamen Versuch wert
sor gunulla und ich sind morgen wieder
zuständig vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse
wir empfehlen Ihnen noch unser heute
journal Update gegen 045 Uhr mit Laura
barn tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend das ist so ein bisschen wie
täglich grüßt das Murmeltier denn in
lockerer Folge ziehen die ties über
Mitteleuropa hinweg gesteuert werden sie
durch ein großes tief über dem Atlantik
das sich kaum von der Stelle rührt so
hat es heute geregnet und auch in der
Nacht regnet es weiter der Regen zieht
nordostwärts und auch an den Alpen
regnet es noch länger die Temperaturen
sinken auf Werte zwischen 11 und 7° und
steigen morgen auf 11 bis 16° das wird
morgen ein trübertag besonders im
Schwarzwald kann es noch länger regnen
in der Südhälfte gibt's dazu auch einen
kräftigen Südwestwind auch nordöstlich
der Elbe sind einige Regenschauer
unterwegs die Sonne werden Sie kaum zu
Gesicht bekommen vielleicht zwischen dem
vogland und dem Sauerland und im
nördlichen Schleswig-Holstein und und
ähnlich wechselhaft geht's dann auch in
den nächsten Tagen weiter vielleicht mal
mit einem einzelnen Gewitter und der
Sonntag wird ausgesprochen mild bei 13
bis 19° ungewöhnlich für Ende Oktober
und ungewöhnlich ist auch das was sich
gestern über den Pazifik ereignet hat
nämlich aus diesem erstmal unscheinbar
aussehenden Tropensturm hat sich
innerhalb von nur 12 Stunden ein Major
Hurricane ein super Hurrican ein
Hurricane der höchsten Kategorie 5
entwickelt mit Windgeschwindigkeiten im
Mittel von zwei 70 km pro Stunde in
Böhen 330 km pro Stunde und das der sich
so schnell intensivieren konnte der
Hurrican Otis das liegt an den
Wassertemperaturen die betragen dort
nämlich um
30° bis
bald